president Trump is dealing with the
North Korean situation during a 17 day
working vacation
he spoke with South Korean president
moon jae-in about the new sanctions last
night the White House says the leaders
welcomed the new United Nations Security
Council resolutions that unanimously
pass the president tweeted a short time
ago working hard from New Jersey while
the White House goes through a
long-planned renovation going to New
York next week for more meetings the
president has spent forty four of his
first 200 days in office away from the
White House at the same point in his
presidency Barack Obama had spent 21
days outside the White House President
George W Bush was away for 67 days major
Garrett is traveling with the president
with a look at how mr. Trump's time away
compares to those other presidential
vacations a major you've experienced
many of them yourself good morning now
president Trump says this is not really
a vacation it's a working effort and the
White House contends that he's only here
in New Jersey because of renovation
structural and cosmetic going on at the
White House but so far this vacation
looks a lot like its modern presidential
predecessors no public events no
briefings and some criticism I promise
you I will not be taking very long
vacations if I take him at all there's
no time for vacation at the time I
remember saying is going to find that
that is just not true
Anita McBride former chief of staff to
first lady Laura Bush knows the
ever-present pressures and
responsibilities that shadow a president
you are gonna need time away and it's
healthy for you but your work is gonna
go with you George HW Bush spent summers
in Kennebunkport Maine President John
Kennedy sailed near the family compound
in Hyannis Martha's Vineyard attracted
Presidents Bill Clinton and Barack Obama
while George W Bush reveled in the
rustic isolation of his Crawford ranch
it was a little more private Donald
Trump happens to be going to a place
that these are his properties they're
members there so it's not truly private
Bush 43 took heat for vacationing during
the Iraq war
and for looking down at the devastating
aftermath of Hurricane Katrina as he
flew back to DC after a nearly
month-long vacation I just want to stay
in the White House and work my ass off
make great deals right he's gonna leave
as was so often the case mr. Trump
singled out President Obama for
criticism 2011 mr. Trump tweeted Barack
Obama played golf yesterday now he heads
to a 10-day vacation in Martha's
Vineyard nice work ethic mr. Trump
summer travel is predicted to cost the
township of bed Minster more than three
hundred thousand dollars this is a very
different situation than previous
presidents where there are family
members who are official members of the
staff as well so they have not only
security but they have staffs it adds up
I think we know as human beings
everybody needs a break or a change of
scenery it's just we certainly expect
more out of our public leaders and that
might be unfair but it is the reality
the president has another wrinkle of
course he is cocooning himself in his
own brand name staying as was mentioned
at his Golf Club and resort now other
American presidents have vacationed here
in New Jersey grant Buchanan and
Garfield are 11th President James K Polk
in case you are curious was notorious
for his work ethic taking up only 27
days during his four-year presidency
Charlie maybe we were just talking about
where President Polk spent his vacation
so much major thank you